bien le bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler de dieu on va se parler
de buzz qui a sorti deux nouveaux
écouteurs ya pas très longtemps on va
avoir tout d'abord celui là ça c'est le
coyote confort ils veulent qu'on
appellera le cul c'est ire mode sont ces
écouteurs réduction de bruit active et
on a également son petit frère ce sont
les sports herbeuse
on a donc d'un côté une proposition avec
de la réduction de bruit active et
réduction de bruit pas si d'un côté
uniquement de la réduction de bruit pas
si on va donc regarder quelle est la
différence entre ces deux produits s'ils
sont intéressants s'ils sont faits pour
vous comment exposition qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent quels sont les points forts et
faibles est ce parce que vous vous en
douterez on ne va pas tout avoir
c'est toujours d'une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat boulanger mercy
boulanger de sponsoriser cette vidéo
pour venir vous parler des nouveaux
écouteurs de buzz que son et que ces
remèdes ou les sports airbus
la première chose à voir sont les
différents formats vous avez une boîte
qui est beaucoup plus grosse sur les qcm
bugs et une boîte va être un peu plus
petit sur les sports urbains
pour moi ces produits sont très proches
vraiment très similaire il ya eu un
positionnement qui a été fait par buzz
sur les qcm mode comme le plus haut de
gamme ce qui est une réalité et le
deuxième comme son nom a dit que ce sont
les sports rien buzz mais en fait c'est
sport irmes bottes sont le petit frère
du qc herbeuse puisque on a quasiment la
même chose avec la réduction bruit
active en moins avec une taille qui est
un peu réduite mais sinon c'est
sensiblement la même chose mais ça a été
très malin de la part boss devenir
positionner ces petits écouteurs sur le
sport pour draguer une autre cible
et puis vous vous en douterez une
différence de prix qui est assez
significatif puisque les qcm bugs sont à
279 euros 95 contre 199 euros 95 pour
les sports et un buzz
la réduction proactive coûte 80 euros
plus il n'y a pas que la réduction
proactive comme différence mais c'est
néanmoins l'élément majeur qui va
justifier les différences de prix d'un
côté comme de l'autre vous avez trois
tailles d'embouts pour venir réellement
s'adapter à vos oreilles
et oui on n'a pas tous les mêmes
oreilles pas tous les mêmes forme de
rails par tous et night donc normal de
pouvoir trouver la taille correspondent
à votre morphologie
ici ce sont des embouts stay heures max
que nous propose bove qui vous permettre
d'avoir une vraie étanchéité sonore pour
vous apporter de réduction bruit passive
du fait que votre canal auditif soit
bouché vous permettra de retrouver aussi
des basses un peu plus ronde et qui va
venir apporter à l'expérience sonore
on l'a donc des embouts en forme de
parapluie qui vont venir boucher vos
oreilles mais avec
petites ailettes qui va venir se
positionner pour le maintien dans votre
oreille ici on trouve du silicone souple
qui va porter une pression uniforme dans
votre oreille que ce soit pour les culs
ceir buzz que ce soit pour les sports
herbeuse dans les deux cas vous avez une
certification ip4 ce qu'ils les certifie
résistant à la transpiration et aux
intempéries
on n'allait pas vous baigner dans une
piscine avec ce n'est pas fait pour ça
mais si vous allez faire du sport que ce
soit avec l'un ou avec l'autre voudra
absolument aucun problème le maintien
est très bon dans les deux cas ça ira
très bien été celle là ou alors que le
positionnement extrêmement malin pour
les sport irmes obs puisque vous pouvez
utiliser également les qcm buzz pour
aller faire du sport
néanmoins quand on va faire du sport
c'est quand même bien de pouvoir
entendre ce qui se passe autour de nous
d'où le positionnement par buzz mais on
aurait pu totalement s'attendre à ce
qu'il nous sorte uniquement un seul
modèle le plus haut de gamme lexus et ir
meuse et non pas les sports airbus est
assez malin d'un point de vue marketing
de proposer deux produits pour pouvoir
cibler différentes personnes dans les
deux cas on va retrouver également une
technologie d'égalisation active
cette technologie d'égalisation active
va venir réajuster en permanence si vous
baissez le son va venir gonfler un peu
les basses pour que vous retrouviez tout
le temps dans sa tion de grave
l'idée c'est que vous ayez toujours la
même sensation à faible volume ou à fort
volume
et c'est plutôt bien réussi vous
retrouvez vraiment une réelle
homogénéité que vous montiez leçons ou
vous baissez le son puisque l'on est
dans le son reste on dit on va trouver
un peu la belle expérience entre les
deux docteurs dans les deux cas c'est
bien maîtrisée vraiment bien maîtrisée
de la part buzz
j'étais surpris même sur les spots à
écouter à dire tiens j'y retrouve
vachement de brillance sens mais aiguë
ce soit sur des sandales ou sur d'autres
instruments
la seule chose que je veux ni regretter
si c'est que vous n'avez absolument
aucun écho l'isr vous avez une
application ses bonnes musiques je vous
la montre dans quelques instants mais
vous ne pouvez absolument pas venir mots
du livre sont sur un équaliseur vous
pouvez le faire sur votre application de
musique mais pas directement dans
l'appli bose ça aurait été bien de
l'intégrer on a des médiums qui sont
vraiment hyper précis pour l'un des
rares qui sont présents sans en faire
trop du fait qu'ils sont pas trop
présent ils vont pas venir empiéter sur
les autres bandes de fréquences entre
ses aigus assez précis mais ce cas c'est
sûr qu'on aura une fois de plus on voit
qu'ils ont été augmentés d'un point de
vue logiciel avec cette technologie
d'égalisation active ça paraît un poil
poussif par rapport à ce qu'on pouvait
retrouver dans d'autres marques mais
malgré tout ça marche bien nous permet
d'avoir des bandes de fréquences qui
sont prêt lâche en partant du grave
jusqu'au début ce qui est plutôt si bien
réussi c'est que vous avez
et commanda tactile pavé tactile à
droite et à gauche s'est sensiblement
les mêmes commandes que vous soyez sur
l'écusson airways ou alors sur les
sports et un bug soit côté droit si vous
tapez 2 fois lecture deux fois pause on
vous appelle deux fois je réponds deux
fois je raccroche et si vous voulez
rajouter un appel vous faites un appui
long à droite hop
elle partira sans votre répondeur tandis
qu'à gauche on fait un double tap et
vous aurez accès aux raccourcis de votre
choix
ça on le regarde dans l'application de
quelques instants vous faites un appui
long à droite vous allez avoir accès à
votre assistant vocal
la différence se retrouver au niveau de
la réduction brute actif qu'on a sur les
qcm boys et non pas sur l'espoir boys
donc lorsque vous allez faire du double
tap à gauche sur les qcm bugs vous allez
pouvoir naviguer entre trois niveaux de
préférence au niveau de réduction de
bruit et si vous faites un appui long
vous avez accès à votre à courcy qui est
personnalisable dans votre application
regarde une fois de plus dans quelques
instants vous pouvez monter le son très
facilement en temps de laisser votre
doigt vers le haut et vers le bas pour
baisser le son ça c'est plutôt bien mais
il ya un truc qui vient à manquer qui
est un peu dommage haut niveau
l'expérience
si vous n'avez pas la possibilité de
passer au morceau suivant ou devenir en
morceaux précédents quelque part si
puisque vous avez votre commande tactile
personnalisable sans votre écouteurs
gauche vous pouvez choisir de passer au
morceau suivant mais ça aurait été bien
que de bas ce soir réfléchi comme ça
pour qu'on puisse naviguer très
facilement dans ses différents morceaux
lui trouver sont des écouteurs on veut
écouter de la musique
elle pose non elles sont belles ces
leçons c'est bien mais le fait de
pouvoir changer de morceau est de
revenir aux morceaux précédents sont
pour moi des fonctions de base qu'on ne
trouve pas ici et c'est un peu dommage
surtout quand vous courrez vous voudriez
pouvoir changer de morceau son devoir
prendre vos smartphones changer ça c'est
un peu dommage
autre grosse différence c'est la taille
vous avez une taille de boîtiers qui est
énorme sur les qcm aide par rapport aux
sports herbeuse vous êtes donc l'on
rangé dans un sac sac à dos sacs à main
sac ce que vous voulez mais dans un sac
parce que dans une poche c'est
extrêmement déformant et pas très très
très pratique
les écouteurs sont un peu plus gros si
du côté des poussières mode ce que
dysport herbeuse
par contre ce qui est très malin c'est
que le boîtier est aimanté vous le posez
donc tout sa position très très
rapidement et il se recharge directement
on va voir une différence d'autonomie
également entre les sports buzz et les
cuillères mode sur l'espoir et un buzz
vous avez autonomie de 5 heures par
écouteurs et par charge
grâce au boîtier vous monte à 2 charge
deux fois cinq heures donc 10 heures
tandis que sur l'écusson herbeuse vous
avez une autonomie de 6 heures par
écouteurs de charge de la même manière
grâce au web si vous notez donc jusqu'à
12h15 de charges donnera deux heures
d'écouté autre différence et quelqus
herbeuse vous pouvez recharger sans fil
grâce à un tapis compatibles
puis vous les appéré en bluetooth 5
points et vous n'avez en collègues que
du sbc et du a assez ici pas d'apaiser x
pas d'appétit x hd bon faut croire
qu'ils n'ont pas voulu travailler avec
qualcomm parlons maintenant de ce qui
fait réellement la différence entre ces
deux produits c'est la réduction brute
actif vous allez retrouver sur les q
c'est ire bugs vous avez dit niveau de
réduction de bruit vous allez pouvoir
venir choisir dans votre application
vous êtes pouvoir assigner de façon
complètement personnalisée à votre pavé
tactile à gauche
à vous de choisir quel niveau de
réduction de bruit vous préférez avoir
de 0 à 10 pour voir que c'est la
première fois que bozz arrive sur des
écouteurs avec une réduction brute
active
je trouve que l'expérience est vraiment
bonne et vieille rattraper leur retard
sont un peu en retard par rapport aux
autres et là pour le coup il corrige
vraiment le tir du fait de l'isolation
passive déjà on va venir scoop un peu
l'extérieur avoue vraiment de trouver la
tailles d'embouts qui vont correspondre
en avait trois ça va donc m'isoler déjà
un peu des bruits extérieurs
et lorsque le couple avec de la
réduction de bruit active ça me ferme
davantage la qualité audio est préservé
malgré la réduction proactive pour tous
ceux qui ne sauraient pas comment marche
la réduction proactive
vous avez des micros à l'intérieur de
vos écouteurs et des micros également à
l'extérieur il va capter le son
extérieur il a capté le sont aussi à
l'intérieur de vos oreilles grâce à un
système de leur phase iib l'avenir
annulé tout le son qui promet
l'extérieur vous profitiez uniquement de
la musique que vous souhaitez écouter
lors d'un appel téléphonique ils vont
venir se concentrer sur votre voix et
les mines et les sons extérieurs
vous pouvez en plus régler votre niveau
de voix depuis votre application se
montrent également dans quelques
instants et le résultat est à la hauteur
et sur les deux modèles que ce soit les
sports boxe voulait que sir meuse
il faut savoir que c'est votre écouteurs
de droit qui est maître qui va se
connecter à votre smartphone ou votre
tablette tout ce que vous souhaitez
votre ordinateur et qui transmet le
signal à l'écouteur gauche donc si vous
souhaitez écouter avec un seul écouteur
et bien ce sera celui de droite pas
celui de gauche parce que si vous
écoutez qu'à celui de gauche vous pouvez
celui de droite au bout d'un moment il
va s'éteindre et vous ne capterait plus
rien dans votre application vous allez
retrouver vos différents casque alors
moi vous le voyez j'ai mon bozene ses
700 euros j'ai mon boss qcm wolski et au
milieu qui est connecté tout de suite et
on sue j'ai mon beau sport event
je clique sur le casque qui m'intéresse
c'est là j'ai retrouvé tous mes réglages
mon niveau de volume que souvenirs
module est ici ou directement sur mon
écouteurs comme je le souhaite à ma
guise
la réduction de bruit ambiant que je
peux dire module est également ici avec
mes dix niveaux de réglages jacques
c'est ici un est favori ce sont ici les
commandes tactiles sur la gauche
mon favori ainsi une réduction proactive
à 10k favori 2 à 5 et favori 3 à 0 je
peux ensuite venir choisir ma source ici
jeudi
depuis mon iphone mais raccourcie sur un
appui long depuis l'écouteur gauche je
peux reconnaître ici mon niveau de
batterie ou alors passer à la piste
suivante je retrouve le niveau de
batterie de mes écouteurs à gauche comme
à droite et ensuite je viens dans les
paramètres ici et là j'ai accès à plus
de choses je peux venir nommé mon
produit si je me sois d'ailleurs il faut
des propositions qui sont assez rigolote
un black diamond black heart caviar dax
tarbes bon je vous laisse passer un peu
l'histoire peut même venir le
personnaliser la plaie comme vous le
souhaitez ils viennent vraiment vous
guider pour savoir comment utiliser vous
allez petit tuto sur le port du produit
comment l'insérer dans vos oreilles
comment loger les lettres trouver la
bonne taille dans beauf ça c'est plutôt
malin vous avez également des conseils
sur le produit pour l'assistant vocal
vous explique comment venir l'activé les
différentes commandes tactiles et ça y
est vous le font pour les deux que ce
soit pour les culs ceir bugs ou pour les
sports herbeuse les appels téléphoniques
et commentcamarche la réduction de bruit
ambiant comment venir la règle est très
très très facilement et également
l'étude rechargement ici vous recharger
sans fil sur les qcm bugs le contrôle de
votre volume vous pouvez activer ou
désactiver détection intra auriculaire
vous pouvez également répondre à un
appel directement lorsque vous insérez
vos écouteurs bon moi je les familles
ici votre niveau de voix moyens pour moi
peut choisir de mettre en d'élever
faible ou carrément désactivé votre
guide vocal ici c'est en français vous y
retrouver sensiblement la même chose sur
les sports hier boys
bien évidemment vous n'aura absolument
rien sur la réduction brute active parce
que si vous n'avez pas de réduction
collective mais sinon c'est la même
chose on vient vraiment vous prendre par
la main on vient vous aider on vient
vous expliquer comment ça marche vous
avez des conditions de produits tout ça
très mal un bienfait de la part de
bosses je vais regretter une fois de
plus ici qu'on n'est pas des co leaders
mais sinon dans l'ensemble
l'application est plutôt bien faite moi
ces deux écouteurs les aime bien ils
viennent vraiment m'isoler c'est très
bizarre de vous parler comme ça que ça
ce que les oreilles j'ai du mal à m'y
retrouver
moi les deux diesel bien que ce soit les
sports hermach voulait que si un vol est
une fois de plus je vous le dis le
positionnement marketing est très malin
au lieu de vous dire on a des écouteurs
à réduction proactive à des écouteurs
sans réduction collective ils sont venus
les positionner sur le sport malin dans
les deux cas je trouve bien à vous de me
dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous avez déjà des écouteurs à
réduction de bruit active bose ou autre
est-ce que ce modèle de base pourrait
vous tenter est ce que a contrario les
sports herbeuse sur plus votre dada
est-ce que vous utilisez des écouteurs
pour aller faire du sport dans les deux
cas moi je trouve bien grâce au système
des lettres que vous avez retrouvé
eh bien ils viennent vraiment bien se
positionner dans votre tête et vous ne
risquez pas de les perdre lorsque vous
allez courir à travers les champs ou je
ne sais où
une fois de plus ça dépend de la
morphologie de chacun est vraiment de
vos oreilles mais personnellement je
serais plutôt efficace a vous de me dire
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
oui ou non mark et moi tout ça quant à
nous on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer bien évidemment à parler de
take vous embrasse aimons beaucoup de
[Musique]